advice from Richard Branson on the  entrepreneurs mindset as seen in zoo go  triple zero having a personality of  caring about people is important you  can't be a good leader unless you  generally like people that is how you  bring out the best in them I'm  inquisitive and I love a new challenge  and if I feel that we could do it better  than its been done by other people will  have a go I'm still may be Peter Pan  doesn't want to grow up I don't think as  work as work and play as play it's all  living my interest in life comes from  sending myself huge apparently  unachievable challenges and trying to  rise above them I've had to create  companies that I believe in one hundred  percent these are companies I feel will  make a genuine difference did I have to  be willing to find the time myself to  talk about them promote them and market  them I don't want to spend my life doing  something that I'm not proud of to learn  more check out sugah triple zero in the  link below